how fundamental is awareness of death
and extinction to the human condition
i think this is actually one of the most
human specific traits and features
that we have it's actually maybe
one of the few things that we only we
have and no one else has so it sounds
scary sounds like what people often
don't like to think about their death
except
now and again or at funerals or to
recognize their mortality but
if you do it at a species-wide level
it's something that is actually an
exemplary human-specific trait that
you're exhibiting you think about
something that is
the loss of not just your life or your
family or everyone you see but everyone
like you and that is
i dedicated it because i think we might
not be the last sentients to have this
awareness i'm actually hoping we'll just
be the first but as far as we know we're
the only and i think this is the
part of the moral thrust for the book is
that we're the only ones that have this
awareness that gives us a duty that only
we can exercise so far so we definitely
contemplate our own mortality at the
individual level
it is true
when you wrote it
it it was really powerful to realize for
me
that we do contemplate our extinction
and that that is a creative force
so the at the individual level
contemplating your own death is a
creative force yes like i have a
deadline yeah yes but the contemplating
the extinction of the whole species i
suppose that stretches
through human history
that's many of the sort of
uh subtext of religious
ideas is that like if we screw this up
it's gonna be over forever and
revelation and every religious text has
some view of either the birth or the
death of the world as they know it but
it was very abstract it was uh fiction
almost in some cases complete fiction of
what you hope or think might happen but
it's become much more quantified and
much more real i think in the past well
several hundred years and especially in
the past few decades where we can see
you know a sense of responsibility and a
planetary scale so when we think about
like say terraforming mars that would
just be the second planet we've
engineered at a planetary scale we're
already doing it for this one just not
that well
well yeah that's right so we're like a
bunch of ants
[Music]
extinction aware sentience ants
that are busy trying to terraform this
planet to make it uh habitable so we can
flourish
and then
you say that it's our duty
to
expand beyond earth
to expand to other planets
to uh to find a a good
backup
off-site backup solution
why the word duty it's an interesting
word duty is something that usually
puts people to sleep i'll say this so
duty you know it's duty is a bit like
death people don't often like to really
think what you wake up in the morning
what is my duty today
most people there are some people who
think about every day people in active
military service wake up it's a very
concrete sense of duty to country
sometimes you can think about it though
in terms of family you feel a duty
towards your spouse your kids your
parents you feel a real duty to them
because you want them to to flourish and
to be safe so we do have the sense of
duty but you don't you know very much
like death you don't think about it
actively usually it's something that
just becomes embedded in your day-to-day
existence
but i think about duty because
this is people think about duties for
themselves but there has never been a
real overarching duty that we all feel
as a species for each other and for
generations that haven't yet been born
and i think
i want people to have a sense of the
same love and compassion and you know
fighting even to the tooth and nail with
the way you protect your family the way
you'd fight for a country for example to
feel the same way towards the rarity and
preciousness of life and feel that sense
of duty towards particularly extinction
aware life which is just us so far this
ability that we
have this awareness of not only our our
own frailty which of course
is often talked about and climate change
and people think about pandemics
but other species that we've sometimes
caused extinction but
very soon will be even de-extinctifying
species like the woolly mammoth uh
colossals a recent startup that's doing
that on their advisory report and it's
it might happen in three or four years
so it's the interesting
point in history where we can actually
think about
preventing death at a species-wide level
and even resurrecting things that we
have
killed or that have gone away which
brings its own series of questions of
just as when you delete something from
an ecosystem adding something can be
completely catastrophic and so
there are no real guidelines yet on how
to do that but the technology now exists
which is pretty extraordinary yeah i've
just been working on backup and
restoring databases quite a bit recently
and uh you can do quite a lot of damage
when you restore them properly yeah
when we bring back the mapmas it might
be uh you have to be careful bringing
that back yes like the best of science
the best of engineering
is both dangerous and exciting and
that's why you have to have the best
people
but also the most morally grounded
people yes pushing us forward yeah
but on the point of duty there's a kind
of sense that there's something special
to humanity to human beings
that we want to preserve and if that
that little flame whatever that is dies
that will be a real shame for the
universe
what is that what is special about human
beings what is special about the human
condition that we want to preserve
that's
why do we matter there are some people
who think we don't there are some people
say well humans take it take it or leave
it they they think they're misanthropes
so the book is on the one sense a call
to misanthropes to hopefully shake them
out of their slumber
but there's some people the words and
throw me just people that uh dislike
humanity there they're just again
they're all just they're called niles
donnie that's a shout out for big
lebowski fans
they're like nothing matters and why
does any they can and they just apply it
more particularly to humans but there
are
endless reasons i think to cherish and
celebrate what humans have done
at the same time many things we've done
awfully and genocide and and you know
nuclear weapons testing on unsuspecting
citizens of remote islands definitely
things we've done bad but
the poetry the music the uh engineering
feats the you know getting to the moon
and eventually already rovers on mars
these extraordinary feats that humans
have already accomplished
interested really a sense of beauty i
think is something that is
uh you know you can't
ask
ants or cockroaches about their favorite
paintings uh or maybe if you could
uh it would be very different from ours
but in either case there's a unique
perspective
that we carry and i think so that that's
something even just the old age-old
question in biology i'm a geneticist so
this comes up a lot of what makes humans
unique and so is it bipedalism is it our
intelligence is it tool-making is it
language all those things i just listed
other species have some degree of those
those traits so it's a question of
degree not of type of trait that defines
you know humans a little bit but i think
for the extinction awareness that is a
uniquely human trait that is to our
knowledge no other species or entity or
ai or sentience that carries
that awareness of the frailty of life of
our own life but all life and maybe it
is that awareness the frailty of life
that allows us to be
so urgently creative
create beauty
create innovation it just seems like if
you just measure humans are able to
create
some
sort of subjectively beautiful things
and i see science that way i see
engineering that way and ants are less
efficient at that they also create
beautiful things
but less
aggressively less innovation
less building like standing on the
shoulders of giants building on top of
each other over and over and over where
you're getting like these like uh
hierarchical systems where you greater
and greater levels of abstraction then
you use ideas to communicate those ideas
and you share those ideas and all of a
sudden you have rockets going on into
space yeah which ants have been building
the same structures for millions and
millions of years with no real change
and so that is the key differentiator
yet yeah that's right we've got an
experiment going right now and maybe
it'll uh change but